ah oui oui je suis satisfaite je suis
satisfaite parce que j'ai fait ce que je
souhaitais faire
je suis satisfaite parce que le résultat
le rendu à mon sens est bien et comme je
le souhaitais et c'est vrai que quand je
me baigne le matin quand je me
déshabille quand je me des nuls je n'ai
pas la vision de la mastectomie froide
pure je sais que je suis une femme qui a
une double mastectomie mai
cet habillage artistique qui me renvoie
à quelque chose de beaucoup plus élégant
et non non je suis très satisfaite
je pense qu'à partir du moment où on m'a
dit qu'il fallait faire une mastectomie
et qu'on m'a proposé d'en faire une
deuxième puisque j'ai un gène brca1 donc
le brc 1 1
il ya beaucoup plus de risques le cancer
reviennent dans l'autre sein s'est posé
la question de bon que va devenir ma
poitrine et à la reconstruction à quoi
ça va ressembler et
je regardais déjà sur internet les
des femmes qui faisait des tatouages qui
faisait des aréoles dauphin à quoi ça
ressemblait la reconstruction et j'étais
pas vraiment dans la dynamique de
retrouver quelque chose qui avait
disparu de reconstruire ou un saint et
d'essayer de 2
d'atteindre l'identique ce qui n'est pas
possible surtout que j'avais fait le
choix d'avoir deux types de
reconstruction différentes donc je
savais déjà dès le départ que les saints
auraient été différents même si
effectivement quand j'ai fait le
deuxième c'est donc la deuxième
reconstruction définitive j'ai eu quand
même un choc il faut l'avouer parce
qu'il y avait vraiment une dissymétrie
et j'ai dû vraiment faire un travail sur
moi à ce moment là j'ai pris vraiment la
décision de transformer mon corps de me
réapproprier mon corps et de ne pas
laisser la maladie mais posez encore qui
en fin de compte n'était pas celui que
je désirais et donc l'idée a germé de
faire un tatouage artistique sur toute
la poitrine sur la symbolique
moi j'ai cherché des choses qu'ils
avaient du sens pour moi donc j'ai
choisi trois fleurs la première c'est la
fraisière qui est une fleur qui
symbolise la résistance aux obstacles
parce que j'ai un parcours de vie où il
ya eu vraiment des épreuves quand même
assez difficile y compris le cancer du
sein
et puis la deuxième fleur c'est leur
hôte anciens pour l'amour de ses enfants
donc ce sont les deux fleurs mais que
j'ai choisis en priorité
et puis j'ai mis
aussi un colibri et une hibiscus ou un
hibiscus pardon et pourquoi pas ce que
j'ai voulu vraiment resté ancré en
martinique lors de la maladie me
ressourcer épuisé vraiment toute
l'énergie pour guérir en martinique je
sais qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
pensent qu'ils cherchent les hôpitaux
dans l'hexagone pour pouvoir se faire
soigner mais c'était clair nos maîtres
dès le début que je n'irai pas ailleurs
et j'ai trouvé ça bien de
d'en créer ça avec les autres fleurs que
j'avais déjà plus d'être esthéticienne
dermographe marie dessine très bien donc
du coup
je lui ai proposé des fleurs je lui ai
dit ce que je voulais et elle m'a
dessiné une bande floral avec
le colibri en plus de dents et après on
s'est vus pour qu'elle puisse le
positionner aussi pour qu'on puisse être
sûr que ça couvre est surtout les
cicatrices parce que les cicatrices sont
inesthétiques et puis j'ai envie de dire
la vision aussi un peu dans semble qu'on
a peut ne pas satisfaire donc elle a su
harmonieusement à la fois courrier les
cicatrices y à la fois rétabli ont un
peu la dissymétrie par un trompe-l'oeil
qu'elle a savamment réussi à mon sens on
est encore dans le beau quand on a
effectivement la mastectomie
survient la problématique du couple
comme on nomme compagnon futur compagnon
va accepter ce corps qui mutile et parce
qu'il faut bel et bien parler de
l'utilisation même si effectivement un
droit construction mais comme jadis et
pas toujours esthétique au sens de ce
qu'on avait avant et je pense que tout
est encore possible dans sa vie de femme
sa vie
un film j'ai envie de dire mais tout est
encore possible parce qu on est encore
belle et ça il faut il faut l'intégrer
il faut se réapproprier ce qu il faut en
faire ce qu'on veut et parce que la
maladie on a décidé alors moi j'ai
choisi un tatouage artistique mais la
réole dessins faits par des
professionnels c'est très bien réussi -
j'ai vu un certain nombre de choses on
voyait quasiment pas la différence
c'est pas parce que moi je n'ai pas
voulu faire la réole que c'est pas
quelque chose d'esthétique non via nos
contrées donc c'est ça j'ai voulu faire
passer le message en disant que tout est
encore possible que tout est encore
possible mais qu'on est encore dans le
beau pour peu qu'on le veut et qu'il ne
faut pas que les femmes
on reste à la mastectomie
pure qu'elles peuvent faire évoluer
leurs corps aussi il ya beaucoup de
femmes qui n'osent pas se mettre en
maillot de bain
parce que bon elles vont pas faire du
monokini mais je veux dire ayant une
petite différence
elles n'osent pas se mettre en maillot
de bain
donc la plage c'est plus pour elle moi
j'ai vu quand même pas mal de femmes
avec des t-shirts vous vous rendez
compte on est aux antilles on a
l'habitude de se mettre en maillot de
bain d'aller à la maison qu'il ya
vraiment vraiment des femmes qui vivent
ça très très mal et je pense que de
rompre ce tabou la de de leur permettre
de reprendre possession de leur corps ou
par le tatouage ou par la réole de sein
ou en portant tout simplement un autre
ouaga ratio les anciens parce que
effectivement la féminité c'est les
cheveux c'est les seins mais c'est pas
seulement ça en tant que femme et je
pense qu'il ya toute une réflexion tout
en rognant nouveau apporté sur le cancer
du sein est ce qu'on doit bien
physiquement pour que les femmes
puissent dépasser ça et continuer à
vivre tout simplement